[Music]
thank you for coming to the pi data salt
lake city
speaker series um i didn't think uh we
would get so many rsvps
we have people attending from the uk
toledo ohio india
various u.s states
and also i see a couple students from my
advanced python course in here also so
there are a lot of different people
here
[Music]
and
we are
i want to go through these slides can
everyone see my slides matt can you see
the slides that i have up right now
they're good
so we're pi uh pi data salt lake city
i'm gonna give you a slight intro to
kind of explain who we are and what we
do and
why
pandas is actually uniquely connected to
salt lake city right
and so we're going to be talking about
pandas and houses uniquely connected it
starts simply with the libraries that
are used that make up pandas so the
python libraries
that make up pandas are one numpy the
major packages so it's the fundaments
package for scientific computing with
python
and it was created by travis oliphant
so
hopefully all you guys out here in the
audience know who this is but he is the
creator of numpy and also he is the
organizer of data as a salt lake city
and so
he's connected in that fact that his
package is actually a core component of
pandas but we also have matplotlib
so the connection goes a little bit
further because
what does all the all those packages the
three packages you have pandas you have
numpy you have matplotlib so how are
they connected to the story right
well
they're all supported by one
organization funded by one organization
called non-focus
so none focus
what they do is they
they've envisioned this inclusive
scientific research community that
utilizes open source software to make
impactful discoveries
for a better world and that includes the
physical sponsorship of matplotlib
pandas numpy
a lot of different
uh open source packages are being
sponsored through none focus and they
have this uh objective for this vision
in order to see this these types of
packages grow and so because of their
support we are now able to fly
helicopters to mars because they're
using open source software that's
supported through non-focus
so what's the other connection well
pi data is actually
uh
a product of nun focus and pi data is
this community of developers and users
open source
data tools so
pi data meetups are happening all around
the world
um
there's global conferences regional
conferences
where you can get together with
like-minded people about data it's not
exclusive to python it's also r and
julia and any other tools centered
around open source data tools
so that's the story and how all of this
wraps together from pandas itself to the
creator to non-focus uh to us and how we
fit in this ecosystem
one of the things that i want to focus
on now that we have this speaker series
going is that i wanted to focus on the
values that uh we want to
have our
regarding the speaker series and i
thought it was important to outline
those is that uh we are inclusive
community that will grow while
supporting each other throughout our
data journey so we want this to be a
great community in which we all can grow
and that we value excellence and we
provide a place where each of us can
continually learn and progress all right
that's enough about
me
and so tonight's uh talk is from matt
harrison uh and we're going to
uh give you a short background about
matt and from i'm going to tell you from
from my perspective and how i know him
and know of his work is
i can tell you he's a leader in data
science world and i can speak to that
because he's the author of many popular
books i currently teach out of his
pandas one point x cookbook all right
he's an excellent instructor and trainer
i can actually affirm this statement
also because i'm enrolled in his
effective book authoring course so
um and he gives back to the python
community and i know this firsthand
because we both serve on a technical
advisory board for open source python
package called yellow brick
he also runs his his consulting firm
meta snake
and he will probably mention this a
little bit more
and with that i want to pass it over to
to matt and let him begin his talk
so
let me stop sharing and
yep i can hear you awesome
okay
should we take two
yeah take two action okay
here we go let's see if we'll cross my
fingers this time um
okay
yay i think i think we're working now
okay
awesome so
apologize for that um kind of odd
i
was on a zoom earlier today i was on two
different other
uh video conferences today so sometimes
i guess my computer just gets overworked
okay so hi everyone i'm matt harrison
i'm excited to be here so as larry said
um i am the author of a couple books and
so
why might uh you interested in hearing
from me um
so a long time ago i wrote this book
right here um learning the pandas
library which i think is five years old
now um
i'm actually in the middle of rewriting
this book so
in the meantime after i wrote that book
i
co-wrote the second edition of the
pandas cookbook
and
i have also
i also wrote this
panda's pocket or machine learning
pocket reference and i've taught
probably thousands of people pandas in
the meantime and consulted on it and
seen a bunch of pandas code
uh over my time so
uh i've come to have some pretty strong
opinions about
what is good and maybe less good with
pandas
so that that is the impetus of this talk
is
some best practices that i've seen after
using pandas for quite a while and being
involved in other people learning it
leveraging it and using it
so um on that note my company metasnake
is going to be doing a pandas workshop
later
this summer so if you find that you like
this talk and you're interested in like
taking these ideas that i'm talking
about and applying them to your data in
a hands-on environment with other
students
follow me up on twitter or linkedin
because i'm going to be running a
workshop for students to
practice these on their own data
okay and uh on twitter i'm dunder m
harrison underscore underscore i'm
harrison okay so what are we going to
talk about um we're going to talk about
a couple things here uh i'm going to
load some data and then we're going to
talk about uh like five things that i
think are good practices for pandas that
uh some people know about some people
might not know about so we'll look at
types how to choose types
what chaining means
this idea of mutation when to do
mutation a lot of people
are confused about that at least that's
what i see from looking at students
looking at
blogs looking at how people are telling
people how to how to use pandas
when to use application or apply and
we'll talk about aggregation as well so
i don't know if larry said it but i'm
certainly open to questions and so if
you've got a question along the way feel
free to ask it you can i'll try and
monitor the chat if you want to
speak it as well i'm pretty comfortable
with that so
hopefully this is more interactive than
me just talking but i'm happy to just
talk as well
okay um with that i'll get going here so
i'm going to load my data so i'm just
going to do this from jupiter so the
slides are jupiter here so i'm going to
be using pandas 1.2.3
but i will say that most of what i'm
teaching here applies to pandas versions
um
that are i don't know three years old
now or whatever so panda is 0.24
certainly this would apply to
i'm going to change some options here
for display in jupiter and i'm going to
load my data so my data that i'm using
is from
this data set right here which is
if we look at it it is from fuel
economy.gov it's i've got it on my
github here but uh what it is is the us
government for every make and model
that's released they list uh some data
about that and so this is a data set
with that data in there so maybe
is this font big enough can people see
this okay are we okay with this font
okay it looks good looks good okay yeah
we got some thumbs up thanks matt
okay so let me know if it's too if it's
too small i can blow it up but i do want
to fit more data on the screen and not
have to be too crowded okay so this is
my data um if you look at the summary
summarization here at the bottom here we
got 41 000 rows and 83 columns so again
this is like makes and models since i
think i believe 1984 and i believe this
goes through 2018 or 2019 is what this
data set is okay so here are the columns
from this data set i just read it from a
csv file um there and these there are 83
columns in here so the things like
number of barrels that you consume
city mileage which is city 08 um
like co2
thrown out by the tel pipe combined
mileage which is combined city and
highway
what the drive looks like the
displacement uh an engine description
the make model uh the year of the car
and a bunch of other stuff as well so
you know 83 columns pretty good data set
what i'm going to do is just
let's assume that a client gave me this
data set and i'm going to
start doing some analysis on it and i'll
walk through this
um
edward asked what's the url for the code
there is no url for the code right now
if you want a copy of the notebook hit
me up maybe on twitter or you can hit me
up on uh
hit me up at my email here and i can get
you a copy of this
um the url for the github on the url for
the github let me
so
if you're trying to follow along at home
you hopefully you can type fast but um
let's paste that in here
there's the url for the github
okay
uh
so
again let's we're going to assume that
like a client gave me this data set this
would be like a process that i would go
through or maybe like someone's trying
to hire me or something and they're like
here's your take-home assignment right
this would be something similar to what
i would do for a take-home assignment so
uh feel free to
you know
if you're interested in this reach out
to me and uh leverage this code right i
think this is fine code leverage it i
mean
you're going to have to riff on it
pretty hard because it's pretty specific
to this data set but uh still the ideas
uh like picasso said here okay so we've
got 83 columns i'm just going to look at
a subset of them so i've got city
mileage combined mileage highway mileage
number of cylinders displacement of the
engine
the drive the type of drive the engine
description the fuel cost uh the make
model the transmission type the range
what what day was created on end the
year so first of all i'll just say that
like i am not a car guru i don't i don't
consider myself to be a subject matter
expert on this data set
so um
generally you know when you're working
with data you want to have access to a
subject matter expert and
especially someone who knows like where
the data came from how it was gathered
why they're missing values what not and
so i'll just say right off i'm not that
person
but i'm going to act sort of as that
person uh in this case here so you know
if there's something i'm missing out on
or someone has some clue that
i'm
telling something wrong or erroneous let
me know okay so uh here's the columns
i'm going to look at and i'm just going
to look at the d types here first of all
and this d types attribute gives me some
insight into how pandas loaded this data
so here's the dirty secret of pandas and
another thing i'm sort of assuming that
you know some pandas so this is not an
intro class to pandas i'm assuming that
you know some pandas if you're expecting
an intro class you're going to be
somewhat disappointed or you might be
lost because i'm going to assume that
you know some pandas but the dirty
secret of pandas and the reason why
people use it is because python is a
slow language but pandas makes it so
it's not so slow and it does that as
larry
alluded to in the intro by leveraging
tools like numpy numpy is a tool that
allows you to use pandas which is to use
python which is a slow language to
manipulate numbers
in almost c speeds and so
pandas is basically leveraging numpy to
do some more stuff
so what i've got here is i've got this
table 40 000 rows and i've got however
many columns here and
pandas is going to represent each of
these columns as a distinct type and
basically allocate a block of memory
in my ram for that so like in 64 the
city mileage is stored as an n64 an 8
byte integer now if you're familiar with
python you will have never seen in 64 in
python documentation or when you're
looking at types in python because n64
is not a python type
int is a python type
right and float is a python type but not
in 64. so again what numpy is doing and
pandas is leveraging that is is it
saying let's make 40 000 blocks of eight
byte integers and then if i need to
manipulate that if i need to add it or
do math operations on it
using modern computer architecture simd
instructions basically can say like we
want to add some numbers to that it can
do that basically
in the cpu very quickly rather than
pulling each of those individual eight
byte integers into a python integer
storing as a python integer doing the
math operations of the python integer
and putting it back in so you you
literally gain you know 5 to 10 to 50x
speed increase by leveraging pandas here
rather than doing this in pure python
okay so i've got these types here
generally when you read a csv file
you're going to get generally three
types you might get dates if you tell it
to parse states i didn't tell it to
parse state so you'll get integers in
64s
pandas will give you that if there
aren't any missing values if there are
missing values it will coerce those two
floats
so float support missing values and
objects you might get a numeric like
column that's converted to an object if
pandas sees some value in it that it
doesn't know how to interpret as a
number so that's that's a basic gist of
these types here so this gives me some
insight into the data i can see like
anything that's an integer i know that
there isn't missing data in there floats
might be one of three things it might be
all floating point numbers no missing
data it might be floating point numbers
with missing data or it might be integer
like values that had missing values
object
object is actually not super fast
because what object means is that
instead of storing like
buffers of memory basically it's
pointing to python objects here so
generally strings are stored as objects
but objects can also represent mixed
typed data as well so
oftentimes when you read a csv file
if it's an object column or a string
categorical type data something like
that or free form text if a value is
missing it will use a floating point nan
and empty value to represent missing
value rather than like an empty string
there so you might get object columns
that have
both string types and float types in
them
okay so this gives me sort of a plan of
attack i especially if i'm doing like
machine learning i do want to be aware
of if values are missing because most
machine learning algorithms will choke
if you have missing values so i might
want to do some cleanup of the data
okay let's just look at the memory usage
of this if i say memory usage and then
say deep is equal to true it gives me
back a panda series in the values of the
panda series the number of bytes here
for each column
i do need to say deep because if you're
using like objects then it will tell you
how much objects how much memory the
objects are using as well um let's sum
those up and it looks like we're using i
think this is like 19 megs of memory
okay so our 4 our 40 000 rows is taking
19 megs by default here so we'll just
sort of use that as a benchmark as we go
along here and look at different types
so what i'm going to do first is look at
integer types
and we'll just pull off so i'm going to
do some operations here i'm going to say
pull off the columns i'm looking at and
then select the data types which are
integers and then we're going to
describe so i'm chaining these
operations together now first of all i
probably wouldn't write this like this i
would probably write this like this way
right here
what's the difference between this
and this well this one takes a few more
lines of code it also requires that i
put parentheses around it but my claim
is that if you write it this way it's
going to be easier to read
you will thank yourself in the future
your colleagues will thank you because
it's
one of my operating standard operating
procedures when i'm writing code or when
i'm training other people to write code
is that you want to
focus on making code that's easy to read
and pandas is really easy to make code
that's hard to read
like if i look at this line up above
here
i mean this starts you know especially
as it gets longer just starts to look
like a bunch of characters however if i
chain it like this what it looks like to
me is a recipe so i'm going to take the
autos data frame i'm going to pull off
these columns i'm going to select
these integer columns from that and then
i'm going to do describe to get the
summary statistics of those so here are
the summary statistics of those i just
like to look at those once i've loaded a
data set to sort of get a feel for the
data what this gives you is the count
that's count has a specific meaning in
pandas it's the number of non-missing
values gives me the mean the standard
deviation and then the minimum maximum
the inner quartiles there so what i can
do
is just sort of scroll through this data
and sort of look how it looks like city
mileage is going to range between 6 and
150
the mean value is 18 the median value is
15 or 17
so okay that looks okay we can look over
here like the fuel cost what that looks
like you look at the range the range
looks like it's heavily skewed most of
these are zero and then some are 370. so
what range represents is range for
electric vehicles so a lot of them don't
have a range because they're not
electric and then year again we can see
the year goes from in this case it looks
like 1984 to 2020.
okay so
one thing you might ask yourself is you
know can i store these types they're
using 8-bit integers with a different
type and maybe save some memory so using
numpy you can ask numpy how much memory
an 8-bit integer takes this is an eighth
the size of 64-bit integer and it will
go from negative 128 to 127. so looking
at that you can see that like highway we
could convert highway to an 8-bit
integer and not lose any precision
unless in the future highway mileage
goes up above 127 but for right now we
would be okay with that however if we
converted city or combined we would lose
some precision on that
let's look at a 16 bit integer and that
goes up to 32 000. so it looks like most
of these integer types we could at least
save about a quarter of the size by
converting them to eight uh n16s
so that's what i'm going to do here i'm
going to say here's i'm going to chain
this operation here here's my autos take
out these columns so this autos is the
data frame with the 83 column so i'm
going to pull out the columns i'm
interested in and then i'm going to do
as type method on this so the as type
method takes a dictionary that maps
column names to the types
and then i'm going to say select types
now and in this case i'm i have to save
these different types because i've
changed the types uh if i just say int
here it won't select the int 8 types not
that i have n16 type it's not going to
get those while i do when i do this
command but let's just look at the types
here that i pulled out and it looks like
like highway was convert converted to an
eight
byte or an eight bit integer and that
looks like we haven't lost any data the
other ones look like they're doing
pretty good as well
um
let's uh now
one of the things you'll learn in pandas
is oftentimes there's like two or three
ways to do something so if i just want
to plot everything that's integer like i
can actually just say select and put the
string integer in there and so here are
all the integer like columns and it
looks like
we haven't really lost any precision by
doing these types here let's just look
at their memory usage from doing that
and we we save like a mag 1.5 megs from
doing that so uh you know not a huge
change but about 10
a little bit less than 10 of our memory
from doing that let's look at floats
okay so i'm going to just
chain this operation to look at my float
type so these are my float types here
cylinders and displacement
okay and it looks like here by looking
at cylinders cylinders almost looks
integeresque you know let's see like
it's 4.0 8.0 and if you think about cars
generally their whole numbers of values
for cylinders so your spidey sense might
go off and you might be thinking
why did it represent cylinders as floats
they look whole numbers are integer like
to me displacement looks like it's it's
not integer like so
let's let's describe cylinders and just
look at that a little bit more
and you can see like the minimum values
too the maximum value is 16. so what
happened there and your hint is this
count up here again count has a specific
meaning in pandas it means
the number of values that we're not
missing
okay so um if we looked at this up above
here we would see that or we can just
look at this entry right above here
there's 41 000 rows 41 144 but
apparently some number of those are
missing and hence pandas converted that
integer like column into a float because
by default the lowercase n64 type does
not support missing values so again if i
wanted to use this for something like
machine learning i might need to deal
with those missing values because most
machine learning algorithms really don't
like missing values
another way to inspect this is to use
value counts this is another tool that i
like to use in pandas all the time and
i'm going to say drop n a is false by
default when you do a value count it's
going to give you the frequency of the
entries for that column and it's going
to put in the index
the call the values from the column and
then the counts in the series values
over here so you can see like there are
fifteen thousand four cylinder cars and
here we see our answer here 206 of them
are missing so presumably again not a
subject matter expert but presumably
this is like electric vehicles that
don't have cylinders right i don't i
don't think uh
electric engines have cylinders so you
might want to inspect this so let's use
some code to inspect it i'm going to say
from autos pull off the columns i'm
interested in and let's just query that
i'm going to say cylinders.na so pandas
has a query method that allows you to
do some pseudo sql-esque combined with
some python code in there so this lets
us
quickly look up where these values are
missing you can see that my index is now
no longer starting at zero so these are
the parts where it's missing and let's
just scroll over a little bit and we can
see like ultra ev rav4 ev rav4 think
explorer electric so most of these are
looking
pretty electric e um
we've got one here
a subaru rx turbo from 1985 that doesn't
have cylinders so this one i don't
believe that this one is electric so
a subject matter expert might be able to
fill us in why this is missing cylinders
um i i presume it should have cylinders
from 1985 but most of these are looking
electricky so
i'm just going to make a executive
decision again i'm not a subject matter
expert but i'm going to pretend that i
have the subject matter expert hat on
here and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say okay let's take our
cylinders
i'm going to use the assign method here
and what a sign does is it allows you to
return a new data frame that has new
columns in it or that has
overridden columns so we're going to
update cylinders and we're going to say
take the cylinders column fill any
missing values with n a with zero
now there shouldn't be any missing
values and because it's now integer like
convert it to an into eight
and then a similar thing with
displacement some of the displacement is
missing so i'm just going to do fill in
a with 0 there let's do that and then
we'll do a describe here and now you can
see if you scroll over a little bit
you can see that cylinders is now not
missing any value so that's looking okay
we do have values of zero cylinders up
there as well now
okay so
we could
do this describe here which is um
a little bit different than what we had
above right cylinders
was missing values that had a minimum
value of 2 but we've changed that a
little bit
okay what else can we do we can look at
these other float things and determine
what we want to do with the other floats
we might want to look at the type of a
float so numpy has this f info function
that will tell you
uh information about floats there's i
info to tell you information about uh
integers so we could look at this and
then we can say okay i want to convert a
displacement to a float 16
and so
we'll just do that and here is our data
frame with displacement converted to
float 16. this looks okay it doesn't
look like i'm losing it much information
if at all i might be you know
maybe need to round that up a little bit
but i should be okay with that okay
let's look at our memory usage after
doing this we were at 19.6 now we're at
17.5 so we've
we've saved about two two megs by doing
this
so
not huge huge savings but we're doing
okay let's let's now jump into the
object columns here and i'll just
inspect those here here's the object
columns i'm going to select the types
with objects and you can see like drive
is one engine description make model
[ __ ] and create it on so just by
looking at these i can sort of get a
feel for what's going on here it looks
like drive is pseudo categorical what do
i mean by categorical it has low
cardinality what do i mean by
cardinality that's jargon that
people use to describe how many unique
values there are so probably not a lot
of unique values for drive um that tells
me that this might be a candidate for
converting to a category type a category
type is a special type and pandas that
can save us a lot of memory we also have
this engine
disk
which is the engine description column
and it looks like it's got like
parentheticals in here ffs it's got
missing values here and then it's got
like ffs comma turbo
ffs so this is looking maybe categorical
but maybe a little bit free form we've
got some like double print
parentheticals in here so this is one
that we might need to explore a little
bit more it's not clear by looking at
this like
there's comma sometimes sometimes
there's this this looks like it's
actually derived from like a free-form
text
so
freeform text is the bane of most data
people and this looks like this is going
to be maybe annoying make probably
categorical oh looks like matt said uh
this is a mazda rotary engine for that
1985 one okay i don't know what a rotary
engine is but maybe
um
so make is probably categorical i think
there's like a hundred different makes
in here of 40 000 model models
pseudo-categorical i mean it's going to
have a high cardinality but
you might have like testarossa over five
years or something but sometimes you'll
see like
you know there's 20 different versions
of camrys or something like that
transmission transmission looks like
it's probably categorical and then
created on actually looks like it's a
date right and
by default when you read a csv file it
doesn't have type and so
it doesn't know that this is a date so
we might want to convert this to a date
um there's a question from kalin and
kalyn asks is it necessary
to remember the different conversions
like int 8 float 16 etc um
it's not necessary kalin
what you'll find is that pandas requires
you to have your data in memory
and so
a lot of the time you can save quite a
bit of memory by changing the the
default data type and basically
you know a lot of my clients are like
how do i fit more data into memory well
if you change the types
a lot of times you can save a lot of
memory and then you can analyze more
data but it it's not necessary um i
would say this kaelin i
or sorry it's not kalyan i believe um
i would say that you should at least
inspect your columns and try to
understand them a little bit and you can
see that i'm sort of walking through
this process of exploring the columns as
i'm going so we call this exploratory
data analysis
and
you know
if you're just an analyst or if you're
doing machine learning i highly
recommend doing this i highly recommend
doing this manually
not like using some tool that just says
oh
calculate all these summary statistics
and then just briefly looking over that
why manually because you're going to get
a better feel for the data you're going
to be able to dive into the data you can
try things out that sort of thing as
we're doing this so uh to like matt's
point you know
if if if this was like a real
client you know i would be asking that
subject matter expert you know what's
going on with that mouse i think what
what is that rotary engine and how do we
deal with that right
and so
if you just sort of skim over this you
might miss things like that
okay so
drive i said drive looks categorical how
do i determine if it's categorical uh
that value counts is a super good way to
do that so i do like that value counts
there we go you can see that there's
what one two three four five six seven
eight nine so there's like nine unique
values in here we can see that man is
one of them so that's kind of
interesting like um
what cars don't have a drive
we might want to explore that a little
bit as well like how do we deal with
that
let's look at that for a little bit so
i'm just going to do this query here
let's look at where the
the drive is missing
and we have like an ultra ev i think a
hyper mini
alfa romeo spider velocity from 1984. so
we have like some some evs some electric
vehicles here that are missing values we
have a lot from 1984 like a corvette
that's missing a drive a nissan 300 it's
missing a drive a mercury ground marquee
wagon that was a great year for wagons
so it looks like you know a lot from
maybe 1984 missing drive
some from 1999 that look like electric
are missing drives and so this this
might be something that requires a
little bit more thought right is this
a case where uh when they started
collecting this data in 1984 they didn't
have drives and entry there and so
maybe
maybe we need to like explore that a
little bit more and so
i mean i i don't have this here but i
can do something like this where i say
autos
dot co we're gonna pull off calls here
and then we could do a group by
and
we could group by the year
and then we could pull off the drive
and then we could do n unique
for the year
okay so
um
there's a number of unique drives for
each year it looks like we do have
drives for 1984 right
so
maybe it's not the case that all 1984
cars are missing drive but apparently
some of them are
and again talk to a subject matter
expert see what they say
with respect to that so what i'm going
to do
again i'm going to just pretend that i'm
a subject matter expert i'm going to say
if drive is not there i'm going to fill
it in with other and then i'm going to
convert it to a category
okay so
and then what what i'm going to do as
well
as you can see down here in this as type
i'm converting the make to a category as
well so let's do those two changes and
now look at the sum of our memory and
our memory's now gone down to 12 from
19. so we basically saved almost 30
percent from converting two of our
columns to
categorical columns so
you can see that if you go through this
step um
kalian that
you can save quite a bit of memory and
oftentimes this will make a lot of
string operations faster if you do this
as well
okay i'll just cruise through the rest
of this here um let's look at
transmission here's transmission i i'm
doing my value counts here again drop n
a's faults to see if there are missing
values there's there's 11 that don't
have a transmission whatever that means
again not quite sure so could be some
sloppy data in there but but when i look
at this column what what sort of stands
out to me is that it looks like this is
a column that's representing two pieces
of data one piece of data is whether
it's automatic or manual and the other
one is how many speeds in there so we've
got an automatic four speed a manual
five speed automatic three speed an
automatic s6
this looks like
i'm assuming this is a six speed again
talk to subject matter expert but not
quite clear we got variable gear ratios
so that's
who knows what that is maybe that's you
know
one of these that has multiple speeds
it's automatic so you know
you have like these nissans that have
whatever infinite speeds or whatever in
them um so it looks like there's two
pieces of data in this so what i'm going
to do is again uh put on my
hat that pretend that i am a subject
matter expert and what i'm going to do
is i'm going to add a new column called
automatic and i'm just going to look in
that transmission column and see if i
have the string auto in there so if auto
is in here i'm going to say
let's have a what's called an indicator
column that is a boolean true or false
whether it is automatic and then i'm
going to make another column here called
speed
and i'm going to use this stir extract
which allows me to pass in a regular
expression i'm going to pull out the
digit if there is a digit in here pull
it out
and if it's missing i'm going to just
say fill in a with 20 fill anything
that's missing with 20. so we've got
some that like don't have a number in
here like this
variable gear ratio so i'm i'm just
going to say that's like
it's 20 speeds okay
is that correct probably not but uh
i'm in charge for this data set so i'm
going to say that and then i'm going to
convert this whole thing to an integer
okay so let's do this
i'm also going to drop the transmission
column so i'm going to say down here
drop the transmission because i've
extracted the data that i think is
useful for it i don't want the
transmission column anymore and we're
now down at 10 megabytes so we've added
two columns dropped one and we went down
by another two megabytes by doing that
so we're at about half the the data by
doing that okay the next thing i'm going
to do is work on the dates here um
we do have this created on so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to try and use
the pandas to date time to convert that
into a date
and let's run that i get this red
warning here i'm now at seven megs here
so
another three megs that i saved by doing
that but i did get this warning here
sometimes you can ignore warnings in
pandas but it might be good to read them
this one says est identified but not
understood so basically if if i look at
this created on here
pandas and it turns out it's not pandas
but it's the underlying library that
pandas is using to parse this doesn't
like this est
or edt
time zone in there so i'm going to go
through one more step to just make
pandas happy and not worry about that
i'm going to replace edt with -4 and est
with -5 using a string operation and
then with that series i'm going to throw
that into two date time let's run that
and you can see when i run that i don't
get the error anymore so this placates
pandas pandas is now happy and i'm also
pulling out the engine description and
looking at the individual description
now so i have fixed my date times now
let's look at engine description here
are the unique values for indian
description it looks like there's almost
600 of them a lot of uh
one-offs here at the end they only have
one entry in them this is really
suspicious again like i said this looks
almost free-form like gmp-4 with eight
spaces then some parenthetical here and
then a space some other parenthetical so
again this is sort of the bane of most
people who are dealing with data
um
16 000 of them are missing um a lot of
them have this ffs in there so i'm going
to make an executive decision here this
is sort of free form but what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to make an
indicator column that says maybe i do
care about the ffs being in there so i'm
just going to indicate whether ffs was
in the description column otherwise i'm
going to drop the engine description
column as well so let's do that
we're back at like eight megs after we
do that
okay so at this point i
i've roughly gone over most of the
columns that i care about and i you see
that
i have not made intermediate variables
along the way i've just chained this
operation and built it up as i'm going
so this is i think a key point is that
when you're doing data generally i
recommend working from the raw data now
it might be slower it might take more
memory or whatnot but invariably
when you do some sort of analysis or
machine learning or whatnot your
pointy-headed boss is going to come back
to you at some point and say explain
this what does this mean and if you're
working from some intermediate data set
you change something one day and save it
and then load it the next day and start
changing and save it the other day
you're going to run into issues here i
don't have any issues because this is my
original data set up here and you can
read this literally like a recipe pull
off these columns set cylinders to this
set displacement to this set drive to
this set automatic to this set speeds to
this that created onto this ffs to this
convert these columns to these types
drop these two columns and then we're
doing some memory usage here but
i mean literally it reads like a recipe
this is what i'm doing to my data as i'm
walking through it so what i like to do
is take this
chain and convert it into a function and
then what i'll do is i'll take this
function and i'll throw it back up
in my notebook to the cell right after i
load the data so i have the cell that
loads the data the cell after that is
the cell that cleans up the data then
when i need to start working on this
data set again i don't need to like
scroll through 80 100 columns trying to
figure out what order they were executed
in i just run the two the cell to load
it and the other one to clean it up and
i'm good to go and i can clearly see
each step of what's going on there
okay
so i'm just going to run this tweak
one here and just test it it does work
it looks like it does work here
okay
uh
that's my first section on types
any questions about that
what questions do you have
can you hear me yeah i can hear you
hey this is anir i joined a little late
so
maybe i missed it but what is this autos
list call calls you do is it is it a
list of columns or is it a keyword that
you do when you are chaining
okay so i think amir's question is what
is this doing yes exactly
so
this is one of the ways in pandas that
we are allowed to pull out columns so
this is not a list operation this is
actually an index operation on autos
and so we're going to do an index
operation and calls if we look up at the
top here i can scroll back up here
you can see that calls is the list of
like
these
columns that i care about so i'm i'm
doing it an index operation with these
columns here
thank you
yep
okay so
uh
and
to your point
um i should actually take this
columns here and copy this and paste it
into my tweak function because my tweak
function where i to put this up at the
top like i advise saying i would do it
would not work because calls would be
undefined so thanks for thanks for
catching that bug mirror okay uh edward
says great code awesome that's actually
why i like that not because it makes me
feel good well it does make me feel good
but because my claim is that if you
write pandas code like this and i will
claim that ninety percent of the people
as pam's code i see do not write pandas
code like this if you write pandas code
like this your code will be easy to read
you will be able to come back your code
and understand what you did and your
colleagues will be able to use it as
well and if you use a function like this
you can start reusing it very quickly so
it makes it very easy to keep your
notebooks clean and make your analysis
go a lot quicker
okay
other questions
apologize for drinking on air but um
i will be
i
in addition to this i'm teaching eight
hours of courses today so i just got to
keep my voice lubricated okay um let's
let's go on to the next section here
which is chaining so chaining is also
called flow programming um and the point
of chaining is that rather than making
intermediate variables along the way
which again is what 90 percent of people
who use pandas do we should leverage the
fact that most operations and pandas
return a new object sometimes their
views sometimes they're copies of the
object but they return new objects and
that allows us to keep doing these
operations on these objects
and so i highly recommend that you adopt
this style if you haven't because the
chain
starts looking like a recipe especially
if you put these parentheses around it
it looks like step by step so i do like
putting parentheses around it and
putting one operation on a line makes it
very clear what we did here
sometimes you might find something that
you can't chain if if that is the case
there is a pipe method on a data frame
and what a pipe method does is you can
pass in a function that takes the data
frame the intermediate state of the data
frame and so you can use that function
to just manipulate the data frame and
then return the data frame so i i
recommend if if there's something that
you can't do with chaining leverage pipe
to do it so you have this clean chain of
what's going on here so that this is my
chain section which is actually um you
know what i just showed you up here i'm
just going to pop in my calls there
again let's run that to make sure that
this works and this does work so there
is my chain
okay so comment by edward about
functional programming i'm not really
going to get into functional programming
in here um
yeah i i did closure for two years and
um yeah function there's good and bad
things about function programming um but
i'm more concerned with what i see is
when when i see
something that looks like this so this
code here is what i would normally see
and
and
usually it's not in one cell normally
it's like spread out into 50 cells and
they might not be in order they might be
in some arbitrary order and so this is
what i generally see most people do when
they start cleaning up with pandas
they'll make a code like this now not
only is this hard to read it's also
violating a lot of coding principles
and i get it like a lot of a lot of
people who are using pandas don't care
to be software engineers right they're
like pandas as a tool i don't want to
care about like best practices of coding
or whatnot but for example this is
making global variables all over the
place which is actually wasting more
memory than
the chain does because the chain after
it makes a new object and no one's
referring to that new object anymore it
garbage collects it but this is storing
a bunch of global variables and actually
using a lot more memory so
if you do this style it's harder to read
your colleagues will not be happy with
you you will not be happy with yourself
you'll be using more memory and it will
take more time because when you come
back to your code
you're you're going to have a hard time
figuring out in addition to that it's
buggy um so i'm going to run this here
and you can see this uh red warnings all
over the place um
this is like the bane of pandas
developers everywhere this error right
here setting with copy warning a value
is trying to be set on the copy of a
slice from a data frame try using loc
instead
so
i mean i could probably like say how
many of you have seen this if you've
used pandas for a little bit you
probably have and especially if you have
some cell like this with 30 operations
they're like
um
okay where is that happening right and
then you start like
tacking in copies all over the place
with your code and trying to
just like change things and rerun it to
see if it doesn't do that right you'll
note that my code up here
there is no pink splotches of death down
here right it just worked um so if you
chain not only are you going to be
happier you're not going to have bugs as
well
okay
um
anir says this is me now i know better
awesome
uh edward says when i get the code i
will do some timing and do timing in the
notebook yeah we'll do some timing here
here below edward
okay so uh red red red okay so some
people when they hit when i say like you
should do changing they're like no matt
you shouldn't i'm like why not because
it's hard to debug we can't debug it
like okay why can't you debug it because
we don't know what the state is well
it's actually really easy to debug um i
mean first of all you can just comment
these out and and i like to do that i
mean what i'll do sometimes is just sort
of come in here and do something like
this where i'm going to comment uh this
whole thing out
and maybe i won't comment this out but
i'll comment out like
okay here we go here is the speeds we
just added the speeds column so we can
check out this and look at what the
speeds come is there is speeds okay that
looks good okay now we're going to do
this next one here which is created on
so you can like comment it out and walk
through it and look at what's going on
as you're doing it okay now created on
looks good right so it's actually really
easy to debug this way um in addition
there are other ways to debug it as well
i've i've sort of enumerated them in the
comment
um you can leverage pipe to uh
capture
an intermediate data frame if you want
to so remember i talked about that pipe
command or pipe method
what you do is you pass in a function
and you can pass in arguments to the
function but what it's going to do is
it's going to pass the intermediate
state of the data frame to this function
and all i'm doing here is a sort of
nasty hack here i'm saying in the global
namespace make a new variable with
variable names set equal to this current
state of the data frame so this is the
state of the data frame after pulling
out these columns so let's run this here
and you'll note that the variable should
be named df3 so so if i come down here
and look at df3
thanks to that pipe this is that
intermediate state so i can easily do
ins inject something like this and pull
off inner intermediate state i want to
if i want to debug that in addition i
can do something like this where i can
say let's pipe this and here i'm using a
lambda function but basically i'm saying
let's use the ipython display code to
display an intermediate one so this is
just going to display it and then it's
going to use a short circuit here to
also return it so this keeps the chain
alive and if you look at the output of
this
um the output of this is actually um
uh two data frames there's the first one
this first one is actually what we're
displaying there and then the second one
is the return value from the call to
tweak autos here so
panda or not pandas jupiter by default
only shows the last thing from the cell
but we're explicitly printing out the
data frame along the way as well so
those are various ways to debug this i
claim this is a lot easier than uh
building stuff up and keeping a bunch of
random things all over the place it's
just messy
um
edward says why display and not print
i mean if you want to do print you can
the thing about display is the display
leverages the fact that
jupiter and pandas have this nice little
treaty where if you show a data frame in
jupiter
it prints it in this fancy html version
where you can like get zebra striping
and highlight over them if you do a
print it's going to print the text
version of it which is going to be
harder to read
uh kellyanne says type is interesting
yeah it comes in pretty useful as well
um
okay edward says well you can display
dunder wrapper if you can i mean yeah
print under ripper okay i mean if you
want to do that you can do that
um i would say that display is the
canonical jupiter way to do that but if
you're not in jupiter maybe you want to
dispatch to dunder ripper i mean
typically i try not to call dunder
methods explicitly and
because they're more implementation
details okay uh so that that is uh
uh this section here so
let's go into our next section which is
don't mutate
okay so another thing i i hear people
say is they're like matt your code looks
okay but like you're wasting a lot of
memory didn't you know that there's a
thing in
pandas where you can use in place and if
you use in place then it doesn't return
a new value it just mutates it in place
and you save a bunch of memory
i'm like okay yeah there is that but um
it turns out that in place is actually a
dirty lie and it doesn't work and now
i've linked to an issue here this is
from pandas here and i've also quoted uh
mr reback one of the campus core
developers from this issue
the quote says you're missing the point
in place rarely does something in place
you are thinking that you're saving
memory but you're not you can actually
pull up the code for a lot of these
methods that have in place on them what
they actually do is they go out and make
a new data frame
or a new series and then they shim that
in so you're not saving any memory
because it's going out and making the
other data frame while you do that so
you don't save anything but now you lose
the ability to chain because when you
call in place you no longer return the
object so you can't chain anymore so
you're going to write bad code when you
use in place so there aren't performance
benefits you think you're doing
something nice you're not you're
actually going to write worse code and
then you're also going to have to deal
with all these setting with copy warning
issues that are just annoying and you'll
start reading through all these stack
overflows and trying to understand what
they mean and we'll just be confused
whereas if you just chained in the first
place you wouldn't have to worry about
any of that
okay
i think i'm done with my mutate rant any
questions about that
so as you can see like over the years um
i'm getting stronger opinions about how
to um
code and how people should write code so
again these are my opinions you can
disagree with them if you want to uh it
has just been you know using pandas
since basically it's been out teaching
people pandas seeing thousands of people
learn pandas and use pandas and best
practices and things that are confusing
along the way
okay another thing that yeah question
yeah sorry matt um so so in place of
in place what is that you are suggesting
just
save it as
as the same data frame suppose i am
dropping nulls
right df is equal to df dot
and a
in place equals true in pl instead of
doing that
i just do what
now the question is what do i do instead
you just don't do it you just chain
right and so if i wanted to drop an a
here i would just stick in a drop in a
right here god you got you you're doing
it okay i got it thank you
yep so just
yeah i wouldn't say like drop an a and
then in in place is equal in fact if you
say in place is equal to true right here
um
you
um because we're returning the result of
this it's going to return none because
when you say in place is equal to true
you no longer return the data frame you
return none which is another thing
that's kind of confusing
uh just from like a computer science
point of view like theoretically like
if you have an interface and
sometimes you return something and
sometimes you don't
that actually makes it hard for people
to read things and understand why things
happen because now you have to keep in
your mind like am i returning something
or am i not returning something right
it's just another cognitive overhead
that if you just don't use in place you
shun it you don't have to worry about
that
okay other questions
okay
let's talk about application and
you can see uh
i mean sort of cutting to the chase
right here don't apply if you can so we
we've got our data
autos 2 here um now this is very
us-centric i mean it's from the us
government but uh assume that we want to
be more like eurocentric or the rest of
the world us is miles per gallon i think
the rest of the world is like uh liters
per 100 kilometers right so whatever
that means i'm not quite sure but
apparently this is the formula to
calculate that right so i can say let's
take city 08 which is the mileage for a
car and let's apply this python function
here to convert a value from miles miles
to gap miles per gallon to liters per
100 kilometers if you do this it looks
like it works right awesome
note that this is using the apply so
it turns out that you can also just do
this operation
right like this you can say 235 divided
by cd08 and this gives you the same
results so these look very similar
however
again this is one of those
devils in the details here because
you're calling apply here and you're
passing in a python function what this
is going to do is it's going to pull out
each individual entry from that series
convert it to a python object pass the
individual entry into this and then
convert it back into the pandas object
so there's a lot of overhead in fact
if we were to time this so i'm going to
use percent percent time it which is a
jupiter construct here to do some micro
benchmarking on this uh
basically uh from my computer depending
on when i run this the time of the day
um i get
usually around a 50
um
in this case it's not it's a little bit
less than 50 but
i get i get between like 30 to 50
percent slower
using this apply than using uh the
non-applied version because the
non-applied version this right here
again is leveraging modern cpu
architecture those simd instructions and
can basically say here's a block of data
do the division on it very quickly
okay so here's another example of apply
i'm going to have this little function
here is this an american car or not
right maybe i want to know you know are
american cars getting worse or better
over time and so let's do make i'm going
to take the make and apply it and
see what happens if i do is american
let's try instead of using apply here
we're going to use the is in which is a
method that basically is doing what this
apply with is is american is doing
and let's get the timing for that you
see that this is like in my case
a little bit less than three times uh
faster here by doing this right so
generally especially when you're working
with numbers if you use apply that's
going to be the slow route
sometimes with strings apply can be okay
in this case if you have something like
is in that's going to be a little bit
faster one thing to note is that
strings and pandas aren't super
optimized they're using python objects
under the covers so
if once you start doing string
operations
you're kind of going slow by default but
you can still optimize somewhat here
also note that make here is actually not
a string it's a categorical type here so
i'll actually um
re-run this with
with the strings here
so converting them to strings and then
re-running it you'll see that it runs
slower converted to strings
okay so
the the as type here
so the is in instead of doing 1.3
milliseconds is now like 10 times slower
um this other one here is also 10 times
slower uh when doing that so just be
aware uh converting to categorical can
speed that up basically what categorical
does is it basically makes a mapping of
like an integer to the category value so
rather than storing each individual
category as its own string it only
stores one copy of it and then when you
do an operation it just has to do the
operation on the single value so
especially if you have low cardinality
low number of unique entries this can be
really quick
versus changing every single entry
okay here's one that's a little bit more
complicated i've got like an if else
statement so if country is in this
return us otherwise return other so
let's let's try this
and we're going to do a apply here and
then i'm going to do this version down
here which is going to say
it's not going to use apply but rather
it's going to use a sign and it's it's a
little bit complicated because it's
using the where method from pandas
i do like the wear method however i find
it's a little bit unwieldy however i
recommend that if you are doing
something with apply
with numbers you learn how to do it with
the where method because the wear method
is going to go that fast path whereas
apply is going to go the slow path you
can see that in this case because this
is doing
it's operating on strings um that using
the where is going to be in this case
it's a little bit slower than doing
apply
um but if we were not operating on
strings if we were operating on um
numbers the wear would be a lot faster
there
here's another option here we can use np
select this is something that i wish was
in pandas that is not in pandas what mp
select does is it allows you to
specify a list of booleans and then if
those wherever those booleans hold true
you specify a value to put into those
places so it basically lets you kind of
make like a switch statement where you
say if this is true put in this value if
this is true put in this value but it's
a vectorized version of that
again because this is on strings it's
not super fast but if it were on numbers
and you had like an if else you can
basically do an if else here you can do
an if else by chaining a bunch of where
statements but it's a little bit hard to
read
so in this case the np select is
is
not really shining through here just due
to because it's working with strings
okay so that is my apply rant the
takeaway here again is if you're doing
numeric processing avoid apply if you're
using strings
you're sort of already going down the
slow route
but some operations might be faster
using like is in than using apply with
strings
okay questions about that
questions do you have
so
with this apply or assign process
there should not be any use case
where
we would do a for loop right i mean i
come from traditional pl sql and vb
background so i i have i mean my my mind
is tuned to do a for loop every time i
see a data set
but what you are saying is
big no for pandas right
yeah question when should i be using a
for loop um
if so so here's my advice on for loops
if you find yourself using a for loop
your spy descent should go off and you
should be thinking this is a slow path
because i'm using a for loop i'm not
being able to take advantage of modern
cpu architectures i'm going through
python rather than this block of memory
that's in my data is there some way that
i can do a for loop without or that i
can do this well without using a for
loop right and a lot of people say well
i'll use apply and then i don't have to
use a fork apply is also a slow route as
well so
i would recommend
trying to
aware np select these are
basically the the tools sets that we
have
for not using for loops
when i actually used a for loop with
pandas
working on my book the other day so i've
got a
in one in my book
i have a plot
let's see if i have it in my old book
i think i have it in my old book let me
pull it up i can put on my face my
camera i think here i have a plot in
here where i annotate the plot
uh never mind i don't have it here it's
not in this book
um
okay i'm not i'm not gonna pull it up
because i just rebooted my machine it
was on it was on a browser but it wasn't
there but basically i annotated the plot
i had some line plot and then i had and
so i plotted a line that had like
elevation for an ultra running marathon
and then um
at each point
um where i had that elevation was
actually a like way station a checkpoint
along the way of the race and i had
another column which was a string column
and i pulled out that string column and
stuck it in the plot so you could see uh
on the plot where that point was right
and so to annotate that using matplotlib
i actually used a for loop to say for
each value in the series um actually
actually iterated over the whole data
frame
um so i said four
i did an iter rows to iterate over the
rows because that would give me the x
and y location because the x location
was like mileage and the y location was
elevation so i used the x and y from the
row and also the label from the row and
then used matplotlib to plot those out
and i did a for loop into each of those
plots along the way so i think you know
if you're doing something like that it's
okay but it you know it if you're like
tempted to like use a for loop in pandas
generally
you should think twice about that does
that answer your
question it does it does thanks man
other questions
okay
my last point here is just to master
aggregation and it's not really a rant
per se but just um
uh
generally aggregation is something that
your boss wants you to report on right
if you're going
say i work at a candy store i'm a
cashier at a candy store and the boss
comes in and says how are we doing today
the boss really unless they're like
really bored doesn't really want to know
that sally came in about a tootsie roll
and a lollipop and a candy bar and then
billy came in about two candy bars and a
tootsie roll and a stick of gum and then
cindy came in and bought one candy bar
and two tootsie rolls your boss doesn't
care about the details what they want is
an aggregation they want you to say we
had 28 people come in today the average
purchase order size was five dollars and
32 cents we sold 628 pieces of candy
right we're going to collapse that
information or we're going to aggregate
it those are the sorts of things that
most people want to be reported on they
a lot of people don't care about the
details now again i did say work with
raw data because inevitably someone's
going to ask you about the details so
you do want to be able to go back to the
details and that's sort of like usually
a one-off type of thing but
generally people are going to ask you
about aggregations and pandas has great
ways to do this with this group by
there's also a pivoting in there as well
but let's just look at this and again
i'm going to write this in this chain
style i could write this in one line of
code however i'm going to take in this
case four lines of code because it's
going to make it easier to read it's
also easier to debug right because i can
come in here and i can say okay we're
going to start off with autos then i'm
going to do group by this is going to be
lazy it's going to return me this group
by object and then i'm going to take the
mean of this okay so you can see that my
index now is the year i'm grouping by
the year and um
then for
for every numeric column i have the mean
for each year so this is pretty powerful
i mean literally this is one line of
code i've written it as four but you can
do these sorts of aggregations very
quickly
so
one thing to watch out for is if you're
limiting what your aggregation you you
might want to watch the order of this so
let's run this one here so here i'm
going to say let's do a group by year
i'm going to pull out the combined and
speed column and then i'm going to take
the mean of that
so there's our aggregation right there
now if instead of
taking the the mean after pulling out
the columns we did the mean before
uh
the second one here i'm going to do a
time it here uh the second one here is
going to calculate the mean of all the
numeric columns so you're going to pay a
little bit of a penalty for that
so this is like almost three times
slower because it's calculating the mean
of all the columns so
you can you can do something smart here
in this case when you're aggregating say
i i know i only want to look at these
columns so pull those two columns off
before i do my aggregation
okay we're going to do some plots here
so i'm just going to load some some code
to make my plots a little bit prettier
okay so once i've got these
um
so again
here whoops
so i i do like this because i can step
through this right so i'm going to take
autos i'm going to group by year it's
going to be lazy it doesn't do anything
until i tell it what to do then i'll pop
these columns it's still lazy because i
haven't aggregated now i'm going to pull
off the mean and now i'm going to do a
plot of this so
one thing to if you can master group by
implying you can make these plots very
easily one of the key things to know
about plotting in pandas is a normal
plot is a line plot and what it's going
to plot is the index along the x-axis
and each column as a line so i just
uncommented that plot there let's plot
this here and you can see along the x is
the in x is the index and each of these
lines here is a column
so if you can remember that it makes it
makes it really easy to do plots here so
uh per year this is the number of speeds
it looks like the average number of
speeds is going up in our cars per year
and it looks like our mileage combined
mileage is going up it looks like maybe
it plateaued in the last couple years or
so
but over time with this data set at
least the combined of mileage has gone
up as has the number of speeds
okay and and because i've written in
this way where i basically have a recipe
if instead of doing the median here i
want to do the quantile i can just
comment out median and say let's do
quantile here so i'll comment out plot
here's the quantile right
but if i do the quantile here's the the
10th percent quantile so quantile if
you're not familiar with it's like we
order everything and then we go 10 in
and whatever the 10 value is that's what
we're plotting here so this is a 10
quantile if i want like the 99th percent
quantile
um i can do that so this is like what
everyone's kid is everyone's kid is in
the 99th percentile so you can figure
that out really quickly but this makes
it really easy to try things out right
um i can just comment this out if
instead of quantile maybe i want like
standard deviation and say std here and
here's the standard deviation or if i
wanted the variance i could do the
variance here so really easy to just try
different things out and and
if you're using this chain style
uh explore with that
okay what i'm gonna do now is i'm going
to add country so i'm gonna
so let me just walk through this this
code here whoops i'm gonna say okay
here's my autos okay and i'm going to
add uh the country column so assign is
going to add a country and uh so if i
scroll over here at the end i should see
country at the end popped on here we can
just check that there is country at the
end okay other end us now i'm going to
group by now watch this instead of
grouping by a single column i'm going to
group by two columns year and country
okay this is going to be lazy it's not
going to do anything and then what i'm
going to do is i'm going to take the
mean of this
so
i should have in the index 2 entries and
then i'm gonna have the mean of every
numeric column there we go
now this is what's called a hierarchical
index uh this thing in the bold on the
left there are two entries there's the
year and the country in that and then we
have every column here we have the
calculate the mean value for every
column so this is actually pretty
powerful if you squint at this you're
familiar with
pivot tables in excel
this is pretty much starting to get you
like a pivot table would in excel
okay and and i can group by arbitrary
number of things so if i have some sort
of hierarchy that i want to group by i
can do that as well
here what i'm going to do is i'm going
to assign my country column i'm going to
group by year and country but look what
i'm going to do instead of doing just a
single aggregation i'm going to call the
add method and i'm going to pass in a
list of aggregations so i'm going to
take the minimum value for each year in
each country i'm going to take the mean
value and i'm going to pass in this
function here which is the second to
last so this is an aggregating function
remember aggregations take a sequence
and collapse it so i can define any
function that i want here i'm going to
take a series and i'm going to return
the second to last item from it
sort of silly but just demonstrating
that this is an aggregating function
that reduces those values here so let's
run this
and here we go here's the result of that
we get in our index we have a
hierarchical hierarchical index but we
also have hierarchical column labels
here so for every numeric column i have
the min value the mean value and the
second to last value so again you can
squint at this and this is basically
gives you the ability to replicate what
you do in excel
but programmatically from python so it's
kind of cool
so
generally it turns out that working with
these hierarchical especially
hierarchical columns tends to be a pain
in pandas so i try and avoid that where
possible
but i'm going to go back to a simpler
one here i'm just going to go back to
grouping by year and country and then
taking the mean and then we're going to
do a plot of this so what this is going
to do is it's going to plot the index
and the x-axis you can see that the
index is hierarchical so this might be
messed up a little bit and
indeed it is we're plotting a tuple here
in the x-axis which gives us sort of a
weird plot so what we might want to do
watch this
so here here's where we were at before
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
do this unstack operation this is one of
those things that's a little bit brain
bending but basically what we're doing
is we're going to take the innermost
index which is country we're going to
rotate it we're going to unstack it
and we're going to stick it in the in
the
into the columns
so now we just have year here and now we
took the country and we made
hierarchical columns from that
okay so
this is actually pretty powerful because
then i can do something like this let me
just maybe walk through this i'll
comment these out um
and you can walk through it you can
hopefully you can start understanding
why i like this chain style here because
it makes doing this and understanding
what's going on very easily so here's
our aggregation here i'm going to
unstack it that's going to stick country
up into the columns
okay countries in the columns now i'm
going to pull off cd08 so i'm going to
pull off this column which will give me
these two
columns down here which this is actually
going to give me a data frame that's not
hierarchical okay so now i have uh for
u.s and other countries i have the cd08
my average mileage now we're going to
plot that
and this is a comparison from us versus
other countries for our mileage okay and
the
uh matt plotlib's putting the legend in
the middle there so i'm just going to
stick in this code to stick the legend
on the side
okay so this this is like literally one
line of code i've written it as like
eight lines of code right but if you
wanted to say instead of the mean here
we want to do like whatever the standard
deviation you can you can stick in
whatever you want in here you can try
these different things and and
play with that very easily because we
are using this style of coding here
so here
this might look like a little jagged so
i can i can further manipulate it here
maybe i'll just comment this out and
show you a little bit more manipulation
here so here's what i had here city
if i want to smooth this out one thing
one hack to do that is like do a rolling
average i'm gonna say rolling two and
take the mean of of that and so now if i
plot this this should be a little bit
more smoothed out and you can see that
compared to this one versus this one is
a little bit more smoothed out here so
just
leveraging different pandas tools
okay
questions about aggregation
and grouping
i have a question
yeah so there is one type of group i
often do is actually doing in sql i
haven't found out like what's the best
way to do in pandas so essentially often
times uh in sql you can do a group by
certain column then you want to actually
immediately filter results you use group
by column a column because they have it
having some kind of condition
right there so for me it's always like i
have to put the group by results i
usually you know for now i see the
chaining one but because the group by
results sometimes it can be very tricky
because you don't even know how they
name the column because somehow
depending on what do you do the column
name becomes a little bit weird and
sometimes the hierarchy you often have
to save out
the group by results into a data frame
like an intermediate variable now i see
the results of the data frame and then i
do a filter so essentially i'm using the
brackets to put out my where it's like a
sql corresponding having class into
those uh
intermediate group by results to the
filtering i just wondering you know
whether you have maybe a better way
to do this type of manipulation of data
so you you want to do a filter by you
want to simulate a having from a sql
query yeah so for example this is today
like one thing i need to do is i
basically load up a whole bunch of data
in a data frame uh those are there's a
particular column it's basically id but
there are some of those ones actually
the id is supposed to be a primary key
but i have duplicates in it and i want
to check it in c code that very simple i
just say group by primary key then
having count one greater than one
then that gives me all the duplicate
primary key
if it's a secret table so just wondering
you know in this case i actually did a
good buy i did a count save the results
out then filtered out where the count is
actually greater than 1. i just want to
you know
what would be a maybe a better way like
in your training how would you change
this thing together
um yeah that's a good question um
i feel like i'm in an interview
situation now um
um
i'm trying to like think of like an
example that i can take my current my
current uh data frame and and like
manipulate it to something similar to
what you're asking i mean group by year
in country and then say like where we
have counts greater than 50 or something
like that and then you would want to
filter that
yeah something like that
yeah so i mean let's just play for the
with that for a minute i'm going to say
count here
okay
and so here are for each
year in each country and so maybe i want
where the count is greater than um
so i can say whatever gt
so this this is the whole data frame but
we'll say like where it's greater than
uh let's say 700.
okay so what this gives me is uh this um
this gives me a data frame that's a
boolean data frame and then i can use
this to filter this if i wanted to
um
now at this point um
i would probably use a pipe to do this
right
and so i would probably do something
like this right say pipe
um
vals
gt
and then maybe i'd pass in a 700 here
and then i'd come up here and i'd define
a function called vals
and this is going to take a data frame
here and it's also going to take
some number
and then i'm going to say okay i've got
my data frame and i'm going to say i
want to return
the data frame where the data frame
uh
dot gt
is greater than number
okay and so if you look at this
um this has maybe what you want maybe
you want to drop an a's on this after
so
that's probably how i do it thinking off
the top of my head but there might be a
better way to do it yeah i think that
there's a comment from travis about the
dot filter
method of the group by results help
after looking to it
yeah
maybe that's something okay
yeah that's basically that's what it is
i was trying to say as you said if you
just do a strict greater than you get
basically a boolean mask
just kind of have to put this boolean
mask into
onto you your group by results that's
what i'm saying i end up having to save
the intermediate results from goodbye
then basically apply this mask on top of
like a two-step process
yeah hence my recommendation to use pipe
right so this what i've highlighted here
is the boolean mask
um
and so using pipe
you
can sort of like
make a different variable if you need to
for a while use that to do filtering and
then go back into your chain if you need
to i mean one of the nice things about
this is because i have this function
here i can say oh let's group by
anything that's over
900 right so 1991 should go away here
so
okay all right great thank you for
pointing about that pipe i i wasn't
aware of that you know before you talk
that's something definitely learned from
you talk yeah awesome
uh travis says could you do a filter
from the group by um
yeah you could probably do that as well
i mean off the top of my head i'm
i'm
um
and we could play around with it but
that like i said there might be other
other ways to do that as well
and so i'll say this like pandas
pandas often has more than one more than
two more than three more than four ways
to do something right and so that that
makes it often uh
can be confusing or overwhelming right
but it
sort of puts us in a place similar to
pearl where
you can write pandas code
that
you know makes sense to you but then
when you start sharing or collaborating
with others it makes it harder so again
my my point that i do like to
uh standardize some things and
and and focus on making things that are
easy to read
and so yeah
there could be some way that's cleaner
than this using filter um
i off the top of my head i
don't don't know right now
other questions
matt would you be able to share the
notebook or is it proprietary
yeah question can i share the notebook
yeah there's nothing proprietary about
it it's just not in a public place so if
you just want to email me
or you can dm me on twitter dunder m
harrison i i think i put my email in the
chat here's um but i'll do it on twitter
i follow you on twitter so i'll do it
okay yeah yeah just dm me and uh yeah
there's no there's nothing proprietary
in this in fact i mean i want people to
leverage this
the style because personally i do
believe
that you will be happier your code will
be happier your boss will be happier
customers will be happier your
colleagues will be happier if if you
adopt some of these things that i've
talked about today
okay i'll also i'll summarize this um so
summary um if you use the correct type
you're going to save memory one thing to
be aware of is that pandas is an
in-memory tool so for better for worse
you have to be able to fit into memory
now we live in a day where you can go
out and rent a machine that has a huge
amount of memory right so i mean i know
clients who were like instead of firing
up some das cluster or spark they'll
just fire up a big server on
amazon and do their processing there
using pandas right but if you use the
right types you can get away with a
smaller server right we saw that i mean
i also i had like a 60
savings by using the correct types and i
could probably even optimize that
further
also by using the correct types you uh
you know if you've got something that
was converted to a string but should be
numeric that's going to be problematic
because you can't do math operations on
a string
and then if if you convert things to
dates you get this nice little dt
accessor that allows you to do a lot of
nice handy date manipulations that you
could do with a string but there would
be huge pain and so why would you want
to inflict that pain
again chaining
my take is that if if there's one thing
that i would say take away from this
it's start chaining your code figure out
how to chain it in fact
um i would say my
my biggest contribution to this book was
basically i rewrote everything as chains
i did add some chapters like on testing
pandas and
there's not a lot of code
available hardly anywhere like doing
things like testing or debugging pandas
so
um i think that's pretty nice from the
book but uh
if you chain your code will be easier to
read you will remove bugs it'll be
easier to debug so i
highly recommend it uh don't mutate
there's no point in mutating um
just don't do it
generally apply is slow for math
operations so
if you find yourself using apply or even
worse using a for loop
consider whether you really need to do
that or if there's another way to do
that and then aggregations are powerful
they can be confusing right i mean a lot
of pandas is is really confusing i teach
a lot of people who are like python
developers and they come to panels like
what's going on here this doesn't even
look like python code right so so it can
be confusing it takes time my my thing
is like take a deep breath relax
the more you practice it and play around
with it the easier it's going to get so
same with aggregations
write them in this chain style start
playing around with them step through
what's going on so you can see what's
going on
uh if you like this
and you want more content like this i
mean i i do tweet stuff like this on
twitter
and again like i said i am going to be
running at an idiomatic pandas workshop
the point of that workshop is you come
in with your buggy pandas code or your
pandas code that looks like
the code that i said you shouldn't write
and then we spend a couple days
basically in groups
basically rewriting your code and making
it fast and easy to read and you walk
away from that with a big smile on your
face and your boss will be happy
okay
thanks everyone it's been a pleasure uh
being able to rant to you for the past
hour or so um happy to field any more
questions if there are
but i i guess i'll pass the mic back
over to our host unless there are
questions
[Music]
thank you so very much uh matt for that
talk i
learned more
i will start focusing more on chaining
than i currently do
so
uh even though i did read that in your
book and i read a lot
i did not put it into practice and i
will um from here on out
um
i guess a couple things that i just want
to say uh
is that we the speaker series will be
continuing um
for the next six months we have talks
lined up uh
stay posted on the pi data slc
website um
you can follow up with matt if you want
to get uh access to his um
uh to this to his jupiter notebook
[Music]
you